look at those boats and the dress and
the hair I love everything that's
happening this is like we just we only
allow supermodels on our show okay so we
were I'm talking about our presidential
slogans it's going on live what would
your presidential slogans be from like
your last text so your name the year you
pick and the last text so it'd be Elano
miller 2024 no problem so Chirac more
2020 never I'm finna walk onstage in a
couple of minutes cherish the day is on
Oprah's network and have y'all met Oprah
before you know I met her a long time
ago the first movie I did was precious
and she was a producer on that so I like
met her in that mix but for cherish we
haven't officially met her yeah but she
was at me it was officially she was at
the table I'm so excited because we
walked in and we were both nervous cuz
we're you know it's everybody it's a
table read and this is the point where
you can either keep the job when they
fire you but this is how we were like we
got to do our thing and we walk in and
we see her on this big television oh
she's somewhere else she's got vanilla
so she's skyping in was she's Oprah she
got a lot doing dude
right and she looks you know she's got
glasses on she's ready she's got her
notes she's starting to write things
down and we're like is this us the video
and then right well we knew it was real
cuz when we first walked on she wasn't
on the screen but there was like a
butler
there is cheesecake
[Applause]
okay so resort dia but an Oprah story
first time I met her was just doing her
show because of doing press for seven
pounds with my good story I think is
being at Critics Choice Awards with my
mom sitting next to comment who was like
your mom looking good I was like yeah
she is
and she was like excuse me come in
Oprah's over there so we like went over
to Oprah's table and then she got Ava
Duvernay to take our photo
I was like she was like it's Oprah I was
like okay so then I took a photo and my
mom cuz I'm working on Ava's new show
and my mom goes asked Ava to ask Oprah
for the photo that we took all those
years ago why would she have she goes no
don't you remember
Oprah took it on her blackberry I'm like
no she didn't take it on her blackberry
should do that she's like no you just
need to ask Ava I told it to Ava it was
like I'll find the photo if it was like
not no no no no we'll try to take a new
one well I'll take once again yeah thank
you
dreams check it so tell us about your
show there cherish the day oh that was
me yesterday is a new anthology series
it's on own so um each season will focus
on a different couple
so there's inaugural season focuses on
are a couple gently James and Evan
Fisher and what makes it cool and
different than your regular romance show
is that each episode takes place over a
24-hour period so you're really able to
get in there and get to know the
characters and it's chronological but
it's like the first episode is when we
meet the next episode is like a year
later and so on and so forth so we
follow them over the course of about
five years in these 24 hour increments I
would
to the gorgeous and you sound funny did
you know each other
y'all knew each other before you work
together yeah while I went to college
with his wife yeah oh yeah and y'all
just randomly ended up being chosen to
be in this together that's crazy yeah we
read for sure yeah we read and when I
read with Alana there was a lot of like
personality chemistry cuz you knew each
other yeah and it was comfortable yeah a
lot trust a lot of safety there that's
all is that like a lot of I'm not an
actress is that a lot of it like when
you go in you have to have chemistry
with the other person is that a lot of
how you get the job or you don't
yeah they become chemistry reduced room
with everyone I will not stop talking
until you subscribe to my youtube
channel that's right and I could talk a
lot seriously not gonna stop yep still
here not going anywhere I see you don't
walk away from this